which listing is only for men
weightlifting is good to make you big
and bulky which lifting is better for
the joints if you stop lifting your
muscle comes to fat it's all about the
number of the skill all these statements
are absolute crap if you've been lifting
I'm sure you've already seen the
benefits if you're unsure or insecure
about the weight lifting what does this
video through because I want to change
your perception and I want you to start
lifting so let's talk about why women
should lift weights the benefits and
also the myths burn more fat if you
exercise at your optimal level you will
be burning fat you might be wondering
why then do I have to lift weights kind
of just do cardio and burn fat let's
understand the difference between
aerobic exercises in this case I'll be
referring to moderate intensity cardio
versus anaerobic exercises which I'll be
referring to as intense strength
training when you only do cardio you
burn fat only during the workout and it
stops shortly after the workouts now if
you include strength training you
increase your metabolic rate and your
body continues to burn fat after the
workout even while at rest this is also
known as the active burn effect I'm not
sure about you but I definitely want my
body to be a fat-burning machine even
when I'm not exercising ladies shape
your curves the best way to bring out
your beautiful curves is to add strength
and muscle if you add my fitness icons
toned body I can assure you they do not
only do cardio in fact weight lifting is
a big part of their fitness routine
lifting weights is going to change your
shape giving you a toner and stronger
look and change the way you fit into
your clothes Korea alone if not don't
get me wrong cardio is extremely
important and should be part of your
fitness routine yes you can lose body
weight by doing cardio but with very
little muscle mass you will look skinny
fast or flabby now when you combine
cardio with weight lifting it's going to
add beautiful curves to your body giving
you a firmer bot to the legs
slimmer waist and also better posture
and I can assure you you will look good
in whatever you choose to wear build and
maintain muscles so when you start
lifting from a young age or even when
you're older you will preserve and
rebuild muscle fibers between the ages
of 30 to 17 we women lose about 22
percent of our total muscle and as we
age our body will increase in fact and
decrease in muscle mass muscle is about
18% more dense compared to fat so one
ton of muscle takes up less space
compared to one pound of fat here are
two pictures comparing two different
women at exactly the same weight the
woman who lives is slimmer because she
has more muscle mass and less fat
compared to the other woman so if you
want to look slim even when you're older
start lifting now and no ladies you will
not bulk up okay that is one of the
biggest myths we should all stop
believing we women do not have enough
muscle building hormones to pack on
muscle mass as easily as the men do
there is a big and bulky women
bodybuilders do not just lift weights
and it clean to achieve that body they
have a very strict diet train intensely
and take specific supplements to achieve
their figure and they've probably been
training for many years to achieve their
goal so know ladies you will not bulk up
unless you intentionally train and eat
to bulk up the next point is to get
stronger bones osteoporosis is the
result of physical inactivity and lack
in weight-bearing exercises we women are
at higher risk compared to men and we
can prevent osteoporosis by lifting
weights with intensity as a result you
will have stronger bones and better
posture with lifting can boost energy
and mood so if you are constantly
feeling tired lack of energy or feeling
Moody go and lift some waves strength
training will boost the feel-good
chemicals in your brain helps you to
sleep better and just improve your
overall quality of life I have
men who fought depression by lifting
weights
she has attempted suicide several times
and after being introduced to the gym
her life completely changed around and
now she's inspiring those people around
her to start exercising so if you're
feeling moody uninspired or stressed out
go and lift some weights weight lifting
doesn't just train the body it
strengthens the mind as well
when you lift you can't just let your
mind wander off and expect your body to
do the job when I train I have to be in
the zone I'm very focused at making sure
my fault is correct I'm engaging the
right muscles and I will push myself to
complete all the repetitions and sets so
this in the zone moment will strengthen
your body and also your mind and you
will also experience at the benefit out
of the gym that's the focus better
memory increasing self belief and you
will adapt to different situations
better with lifting will make you
stronger and give you more confidence I
have a girlfriend who loves to lift
because it makes her feel stronger and
she likes knowing that she can do her
daily routine such as carrying grocery
bags her children are lifting other
heavy items on her own without needing
someone else's help to me that is a very
empowering and it can also boost our
self-esteem these are just seven
benefits which is you will experience
once you start lifting there are so many
more other benefits such as heart health
prevent diseases living longer and
looking younger so how and where should
you start start by doing total body
strength training three times weekly on
alternate days because it takes between
24 to 48 hours for our muscles to build
and recover avoid training the same
muscles
consecutively resting and allowing your
muscles to recover is equally just as
important so on the other days you can
do cardio exercises for each weight
training session in for a solid 45 to 60
minutes and when you lift remember that
the waves should behave enough for you
to perform between 8 to 15 repetitions
you can do more than 15 repetitions
without much of a struggle then the
weights are too light you need to lift
heavier okay start with two sets per
exercise and slowly increase to three or
four sets I would recommend you to watch
my how to start a workout routine video
for more in-depth explanation and also
the total body strength training for
women to get you started video links are
right at the end of this video and I've
also added more links in my description
box below so ladies I want you to start
your weight training sessions today okay
be sure to like this video share this
video with your girlfriends and get them
to lift and also subscribe to my youtube
channel for more fitness videos workout
videos and also nutritional tips weekly
are the best